this video is brought to you by
Squarespace the all-in-one platform
where entrepreneurs can easily create
and customize their own personal or
professional website more on Squarespace
later in the video so hello and welcome
to yet another episode of biographics
I'm your host kyl Smallwood and today
we're talking about the Lost Battalion
and as with all the videos here at
biographics this one is based on a
script submitted To Us by one of our
writers this one being Ben Adelman whose
name I've been mispronouncing this
entire time for which I can only
apologize and on the subject of
pronunciations cuz there's German some
French pronunciations in here I have
looked up pronunciations from native
speakers historians Scholars all that
good stuff hopefully there'll be few to
know mistakes if I do make one let me
know in the comments as I know you will
because this is a video about something
to do with the war which I know from
experience as a writer and researcher
myself is the number one subject people
online like to argue about in the
comments so get right to
that when the United States entered the
first world war in 1917 great effort was
expended by the government to get public
firmly behind the war effort one of the
best ways to get people into the proper
martial spirit is the creation of war
heroes of which America had more than
its fair share despite only
participating in the war for a
relatively short period of time all
things considered and in arguably one of
the stories that captivated American
audiences back home the most was that of
the so-called lost Battalion and it
really isn't hard to see why a few
hundred American soldiers trapped Behind
Enemy for 5 days without Food Supplies
surrounded and constantly attacked by
the enemy bravely withstanding repeated
assaults on their position until they're
finally rescued by their comrades it's
the kind of story that gets everybody's
attention which is why it's so bizarre
that today few Americans have even heard
of a lost Battalion much less the Gory
details of what those men needed to do
simply to survive then again if we told
you something you already knew this
likely wouldn't be a very interesting
video would it and that's you know me
quoting directly from the script here
but I know for a fact that a good
majority of the people people watching
this already know pretty much everything
about the Lost Battalion they're
watching this video to see if we make
any mistakes they can correct in the
comments uh or if you like myself you're
just a a fan of the band Sabaton and
like just like hey that's a cool song I
wonder if it's oh oh God this is cool
people don't know Sabaton is a heavy
metal band who sing near exclusively
about World War II and like they just
they have their own channel which is
where I got the pronunciations for this
video from where the lead singer goes
around with his story about all the um
events from World War II they have sung
about in their songs to make sure
they're as historically accurate as
possible they're cool band like go give
him a listen if you're all into a heavy
M there's one about the Lost Battalion
which is you know 3 minutes long much
shorter than this video is going to
be October 2nd 1918 the American
expeditionary Force the a commanded by
General John Blackjack persing is
beginning the seventh day of its moose
agon offensive in northeastern France
and again moose Mouse Mo M I've heard it
pronounced out multiple different ways
I'm going to go with moose because
that's what again what I heard the guy
talking about on YouTube with the accent
most similar to my own that's how they
pronounced it the offensive the largest
operation involving United States troops
in history up to that time is part of a
general plan by all Allied Forces on the
Western Front to gain as much territory
as possible before winter set in setting
them up for one final offensive in the
spring of 1919 that would finally finish
the so-call called Great War in order to
field an Army of 2 million men the
United States had embarked on a massive
recruitment drive when they entered the
war in 1917 most of the soldiers of the
a who were nicknamed doughbys were
civilians that had either volunteered or
been drafted into uniform one of these
men was 35-year-old major Charles Whitty
commanding officer of the first
Battalion the 308 Infantry Regiment
Whitty a Harvard educated lawyer who
left a thriving New York law practice
behind when his country called didn't
look much like a soldier at first glance
frail and bookish wearing large
spectacles and walking around with a
strange loping gate that earned in the
nickname Galloping Charlie but he more
than earned his stripes since arriving
in France with the 77th division in
April 1918 impressing those above and
below him with his intelligence and calm
demeanor even under heavy enemy fire in
the early morning of October 2nd major
Whitty was given orders for the day's
attack the 308 job was to continue their
Advance within the Argon Forest a
heavily wooded and hilly area the
Germans have spent years fortifying
since occupying it earlier in the war
WHL and his men had been fighting in the
Aron since September 26th experiencing
firsthand all the horrors of trench
warfare that had evolved since the War
Began in 1914 machine guns bar wire and
the dreaded artillery barges which
inflicted 80% of the casualties on both
sides and it's worth pointing out that
many of these shells contained an
infantryman's worst nightmare poison gas
to which virtually all of the American
soldiers on the Western Front have been
exposed to at this point in addition to
the Germans the Americans had to deal
with the unseasonably cold temperatures
and a persistent rain that soaked their
uniforms through have been ordered to
leave their overcoats rain PCH CH in
tense behind when the offensive began to
make their packs lighter casualties were
mounting and morale was understandably
low and nobody realized it at the time
but when Charles Whitty and his men went
over the top and began their attack that
morning things were about to get just so
much
[Music]
worse the advance in the Argon had been
slower than the Army plan that had
anticipated no allowance had really been
made for the rough terrain or the
toughness of the German positions
instead the delay was blamed simply on
incompetence or the over cautious
officers who didn't want to attack the
Fortified German positions who had
machine guns and grenades the call went
out from General Ping's desk the pace
needed to be picked up or heads will
begin to roll one of the officers
feeling the heat was Major General
Alexander the 77th division's Commander
the line needed to move forward and he
continually Harang his officers and they
needed to press the attack in an effort
to motivate them Alexander lied to his
subordinates telling them that they were
holding up the advance of the units to
the left and and to the right of them
with that delay in fact the attack had
stalled out all along the line in they
are gone but Alexander made his Brigade
and regimental commanders believed that
their neighboring units were further
ahead than they actually were which
would be a key factor in what happened
next Whitt's troops attacked in
accordance with their orders being
repulsed in the morning but finding more
success in the afternoon advancing to
their objective a steep Hillside in the
trees called and I hope I pronounce this
correctly the Shalo Ravine they dug in
for the night expecting to continue the
attack the very next morning what Whitty
didn't know however was that he was the
only unit that had actually managed to
achieve their objective that day no one
else had managed to advance as far as he
had far from being behind his
neighboring units he was now far out
ahead of them and due to the nature of
his orders Whitty had just ignored his
flanks because he assumed there were
more men up front to regroup with but
there weren't so this allowed the
defending Germans to slip in behind him
during the night so that by the next
morning Whitty was surrounded by the
enemy totally cut off from the rest of
the American Army so just as an aside we
need to talk about communication during
the first world war because it was
pretty much a continuous problem
throughout the conflict portable
wireless radio communications um didn't
really work because they hadn't been
invented yet and field telephone lines
were particularly vulnerable to being
cut off by enemy artillery or just the
enemy when they tripped over it and just
cut it this meant that the most common
form of communication in the front lines
and command posts was one that would be
familiar to the ancient Greeks just
giving a guy a letter and tell to run
very very fast you know just Game of
Thrones season 8 that all the way all
the way back to the wall just you know
just like who can run the fastest and
who do we like the least basically so
this was slow at the best of times and
the fighting the AR gon was hardly the
best of times it took a while for both
Whitty and his superiors to fully
realize that he was totally and wholly
cut off once it became clear that no
messages were getting through in either
direction because the messers were
either killed or captured by the Germans
wiy now basically had only really two
options he could stay where he was and
wait for his comrades to catch up to him
or he could conduct a fighting Retreat
to break break through the enemy cordon
and return to Enemy Lines had he known
what was about to happen he very well
may have chosen to retreat but it's
likely that he believed the situation
would only last a day or two at the most
since the Americans have been slowly but
steadily advancing for the entire week
most importantly All American units were
under strict orders not to give up
ground under any circumstance a decision
made by senior army officers who believe
that any other course of action would
cause men to turn yellow and run back to
their trenches Under Fire these were all
mistakes that the other countries
fighting on the Western Front had made
and learned from already to in the past
four years of fighting and perfectly
showcased both the American commanders
inexperience with trench warfare and the
disdain with which they viewed their
Citizen Soldier Army in any case Whitty
sent word to all the men under his
command that they were to dig in sit
tight and defend their position at all
costs the first German attack on their
position which become known as the
pocket came later that very afternoon so
Folks at home you may have noticed that
I have changed my outfit and that's
because today's sponsor Squarespace that
act look professional but also stand out
for today's ad read and hopefully this
ticks both boxers so so I've enlisted
the help of my good friend Brad
rollinson from Fai to go with me through
today's sponsor so Squarespace is quite
a paradoxical thing Brad isn't it it's a
website that lets you make other
websites and then you can presumably use
their service to make a website that
also makes websites it's Squarespace too
Cube space keeps me Squarespace has
built into it something called the fluid
engine so the fluid engine sounds
awesome I'm guessing it's not the name
of a jet ski it's not a jet ski now okay
what is it then uh fluid engine is a
system built into each of their websites
which allow you to drag and drop
elements in and customize them in any
way you would like okay so give me some
examples of way you can customize this
cuz I'm very excited to hear more well
you can place things where you want you
can change the colors you change the
text change the content change the size
change colors can
you well now you're speaking my language
so let's say I've used a fluid engine
I've built my website but I want to use
it to make money how do I make my
website work for me Brad can Squarespace
help me here well they can Carl so
Squarespace you can sell products you
can even sell your time in the form of
courses you can upload lessons that
people can learn from you you can
educate people and there's the option
for you to charge a subscription service
for these lessons or you can charge a
onetime fee for access to them all okay
so you can like you can make your
website earn money for you you can
create your own subscription service for
whatever content it happens to be that
you make yeah and if you want to keep
track of how much money you're making or
where the viewers are coming from
there's an analytics page built into
squar space where you can keep track of
all of those things and for anyone
unfamiliar with internet vernacular
analytics are the live life blood of
creating content online so having a tool
that allows you just instant access to a
comprehensive overview that's easy to
understand is very very
useful that's not even in like you know
they have copy that's just me saying
that there very I used to do SEO work
knowing the analytics is super important
so if you follow the links on screen
right now you can get 10% off your first
purchase of the domain or website by
using the code biographics and if you do
you'll be helping us out You' be helping
them out and you know you might be
helping your future self out by making a
website that allows you to turn your p
passion into passion I was going to say
turn your passion into cashion that
doesn't work turn your passion into
cashion hey Square his face you want
that one do you want to use that one
they can have it turn your passion into
cashion major Whitty only really had one
way to communicate with his superiors
his unit had been equipped with a cage
full of homing pigeons that could
communicate written messages back to
headquarters so you know commonly used
throughout Warfare but this was hardly
full proof the birds though trained
could get confused and fly in the wrong
direction you know if a bomb went off
they could also be spotted by the
Germans or R be you know shot not to
mention the fact that you could only
send messages one way and once the
message had been sent there was no way
to really know whether or not the
message had been received so altogether
not the most ideal of circumstances and
as an example of the kind of mistakes
and issues this could lead to consider a
message sent not by Whitty but by his
artillery liaison officer um which
included the wrong coordinates for for
their position and the consequences of
this single mistake were disastrous to
say the least when on the afternoon of
October 4th the second day of The Siege
an American artillery barrage meant to
help wiles's men to thin out the German
ranks was instead dropped right on top
of their position and it's it's hard to
imagine just how uniquely horrifying
experience that would have been for the
Trap men they were unable to get out of
the line of fire because the surrounding
Germans were shooting at them the entire
time a high explosive shell was powerful
enough to blow a man like completely AP
and the bodies of men killed over the
last two days have been dug up by the
shelling and blown all over um their
unfortunate comrades the situation was
later and very accurately described as
being akin to Hell on Earth in
desperation Whitt SE called out for his
last remaining pigeon and wrote out a
message that read and I quote our own
artillery is dropping a barrage directly
on top of Us For Heaven's Sake stop it
the message was tied to the leg of a
male bird named shery French for dear
friend and after some encouragement you
know it was a bit scared of the bombs
going off the Pidgeon finally took off
and headed back for American Life
despite being seriously wounded Sher me
got the message through and if anyone
curious about the fate of the pigeon it
did survive its numerous injuries and
died in 1919 at which point his body was
stuffed and sent to this msian I think
it also got a medal but you know um
we'll have to fight check that one about
this time newspaper correspondents
covering the wall for American
newspapers began seeking out more
information on major Whitt's trap men
sniffing out what they believe to be a
dramatic story their readers would want
to know about the Trap men became known
as The Lost Battalion which as cool as
that sounds is a misnomer at no point
was wi's command lost everybody knew
exactly where they were it's just they
couldn't get to them because Germans
General persing began to realize that
something needed to be done to rectify
the situation because if whitty's
position and command were overrun it
would not only be a military disaster
but a public relations one as well the
orders then came down the Lost Battalion
needed to be save no matter the cost
this was easier said than done of course
the Germans were stiffening their
resistance in the Aron moving
reinforcements into the area and were
successfully repelling all attempts to
relieve the trapped Americans they were
also stepping up their attacks on wil's
forces trying to wipe them out before
help could arrive by this point the
supply situation in the pocket was shall
we say bad most of the men under
whitty's command had gotten very little
food since the offensive first began on
September 26 the supply of Russians
being a continual problem throughout the
campaign and what a little food had been
carried with them was gone after just 2
days the only fresh water source was a
stream at the bottom of the hill but
anyone who attempted to reach it ran the
risk of being shot by a German sniper
most of the soldiers if they drank at
all did so from muddy shell holes as the
growing numbers of wounded men the
meager medical supplies have been
quickly and totally exhausted leaving
nothing to treat them with there was
nothing anyone could do to prevent their
wounds becoming infected leaving many of
them to die a slow and agonizing death
as help didn't arrive in an attempt to
help the Trap men American airplanes
flew sorties over the agon attempting to
Lo locate the Lost Battalion and dropped
containers full of supplies for them the
first attempted aerial Supply in the
history of warfare unfortunately for
Whitty and his men it wasn't the first
successful aerial resupply in the
history of warfare since the pilots had
trouble finding the right spot to drop
their packages most of them were
inadvertently dropped to the confused
but very grateful German soldiers
instead by October 6 things look pretty
Grim in the pocket to say the least
despite repeated attempts and heavy
casualties no one could break through to
theost Battalion which now languished in
the Ravine surrounded by the enemy for
four whole days and at this point even
if Whitty wanted to fight his way out of
the incircle and he couldn't his men
were simply too weak and too exhausted
from four days of constant engagement
and like know being shot at that also
had no sleep no food no water and half
of them were dead or dying so yeah not a
great position to be in and as if all
this wasn't bad enough the Dough Boys
began to run out of something you think
would be plentiful during Warfare
ammunition forcing wi seeing his men to
run out into no man's land and scavenge
ammo and magazines from the dead and
dying it's worth noting that the Germans
weren't having an easy time of it either
already stretched thin along their lines
as it was they were losing men they
couldn't really afford to replace trying
to overcome the stubborn resistance of a
few trapped Americans they decided to up
the anti calling in their Elite sterm
Trooper or storm troopers to break the
impass these were specifically trained
units of shock troops that were intended
to assault heavily fortified trenches so
surely they' have no issue storming in
and taking out a bunch of guys in
basically an exposed position who are
already dead dying wounded or tired so
the German attack on the pocket on the
afternoon of the six was the most
vicious one yet the Americans were
sprayed with a Halo machine gun fire and
pelted with a barrage of hand grenades
which the Americans like took to
affectionately referring to as potato
mashes because they long wooden handles
and I guess you know all the uh people
who were just dying to correct us on a
mistake um uh or tell us something about
Warfare that we don't know um why why
don't we have grenades with handles
anymore I'm curious about that I've
always wondered like they seem like
they'd be so useful I guess like
carrying them is an issue but they seem
so much better suited for the the act of
throwing and they'll see like they
bounce a lot less which you know I guess
grenades do but I guess that would be an
issue because I know that um uh for a
friend of mine who was in the the Army
when he was training how to throw
grenades he got told you throw it you
skim it along the floor so it bounces
around so people can't pick it up and
throw it back or to reduce the risk of
that happening which I guess it'll be a
lot easier if it's handle but still it
seems like you be to throw one way more
accurately it's like whoop yeah let me
know about that I've always been curious
moving swiftly on then the STM trooping
appeared some of them carrying another
horrifying recent invention of Modern
Warfare the flamethrower what the
Americans called Liquid Fire men whose
nerves were already strained to their
breaking point now it's to confront with
the very real possibility of being
burned alive what saved the men besides
the many individual acts of heroism and
gallantry was the leadership of their
officers in particular major Whitty who
seemed to be everywhere all at once just
as he had been throughout the encircle
and constantly encouraging and directing
his men showing little to no regard for
his own safety as bullets whizzed
overhead his subordinate officers taking
their cues from him likewise showed
remarkable courage and calmness Under
Fire even at the worst moments like the
one where the flamethrowers turned up at
this point the Americans engaged the
Germans in vicious hand-to-hand combat
with their bayonet screaming like Madmen
as a fight turned into an ugly all out
brawl with flamethrowers the Germans
were repelled falling back to the pocket
with rifle fire and curses the Americans
chasing after them as for the
flamethrowers several of them were
broken open by just well- aimed shots
from the Americans which resulted in the
unfortunate operators being burned alive
themselves when it was all over the Lost
Battalion was still holding its position
but it was a dubious prize at best the
men no longer had the strength to bury
the dead so they laid where they fell
and there seems to be little doubt that
if they didn't get help soon the entire
Ravine which have been described as a
small corner of Hell will be covered in
Corpses
on October 7th the Lost Battalion was at
its Breaking Point many men barely had
the strength to lift up their rifles let
alone engage flamethrower carrying
Germans in hand-to-hand combat like they
had the day before more and more men
were sustaining Grievous bodily wounds
that could not be treated leaving them
in awful pain they were all starving
dirty shambolic wrecks of humanity that
hardly resembled the strong starw
soldiers they'd been at the start of the
engagement at that point though
something curious happened American who
had been captured by the Germans was
sent back into the pocket carrying a
white flag and a letter addressed to
major Whitty from the German command he
urged him to surrender because and I
quote it would be quite useless to
resist anymore in view of your present
conditions however surrender was the
farthest thing from whitty's mind even
with how bad things had gone reporters
would later write that Whitty told the
Germans to quite simply go to hell but
the major would later deny this stating
that he ignored the letter because and I
quote no reply seemed necessary word
quickly spread through the position that
the Germans had sent them a surrender
letter the soldiers were rightfully all
kinds of mad about it when it became
clear the Americans weren't going to
surrender they were attacked again
including by more flamethrowers by this
point all of the heavy Weaponry was out
of action they had no grenades and a few
bullets for their rifle but once again
the Dough Boys rose up out of their
foxholes and resisted valiantly
apparently attempting to get them to
surrender had inadvertently serve to
just motivate the soldiers who would
rather die in fights to the last man
than give the Germans the satisfaction
of their Surrender by 6 p.m. the attack
was over the Germans once again
disappearing back into the trees wiy
felt that this had been their last gas
almost all of their ammunition was gone
and they had nothing left to defend
themselves with but their bayonets if
they were attacked again they'd most
certainly be overrun well the Germans
had pretty much run out of time while
they'd been preoccupied trying to
annihilate the trapped Battalion in the
pocket their lines have been pierced
elsewhere by a massive American attack
they could no longer maintain their
position and were forced to retreat as
Darkness fell the Germans pulled out and
finally after five whole days of vicious
fighting American units arrived at the
Lost battalion's position The Siege was
over and though they didn't realize it
at the time the men were already being
loued as Heroes back home in
America the first impression that the
leaving soldiers had of the Lost
Battalion was that they smelled really
bad to clarify the bodies of those
killed in the fighting which were pretty
much all over the place and some which
have been blown to Pieces by artillery
strikes from their own positions had
begun to purify and that combined with
the other unpleasant smells the men
being constantly Under Fire had little
opportunity or inclination to use the
holes Dogers latrines made quite the
impression it believed that major Whitty
took a total of 687 men into his
position on the Ravine on October 2nd
when he left on October 8th and we 194
were able to walk out with him the rest
were either twoo badly wounded dead or
missing fortunately for the survivors
the hell they had experienced in their
are gone was the end of that war just
over a month later on October 11th the
Germans agreed to an Arce having fought
themselves to exhaustion the huge influx
of American Manpower had in the end
proved to be the necessary Tipping Point
all across the United States people were
talking about the heroism of the Lost
Battalion stories have begun to be
written about the episode while it was
still going on and long before the men
of the 308 return home they were be
louder as Heroes reporters outdid
themselves in writing exciting accounts
of the story carefully avoiding the more
graphic parts that we've covered in
today's video while embellishing details
to make the men seem even more heroic
than they already were which seems kind
of pointless it's like some of these
dudes like fist F flamethrower wielding
Stormtroopers you know really need to
embellish that just that image alone is
already like you know an album cover it
literally is an album cover a band
called Sabaton sung a song about these
dudes and it's super Metal the center of
this hero worship was Charles Whitty
promoted to Lieutenant Colonel on the
spot upon being relieved Whitty and two
of his subordinate officers received the
Medal of Honor America's highest
decoration awarded for conspicuous
gallantry above and beyond the Call of
Duty 30 of his men received the
distinguished service cross the Army's
second highest bravery medal we'll see
how had not sustained so much as a
scratch during the Lost Battalion
episode yet he returned home from the
war a wounded man nonetheless he found
returning to his old life pretty much
impossible as the demands of celebrity
constantly intruded he was almost
certainly suffering from a severe case
of PTSD which at the time was known as
shell shock and was poorly understood to
the point many of the men suffering from
it were labeled cowards for not wanting
to fight but that's a a story for
another day on one of our other channels
like there is when if you put the Clips
in there's the uh there really harrowing
like black and white videos of men who
come back from the trenchers and the
front lines in World War I experiencing
shell shock and they just don't look
like people like what was left of their
human it's just gone there the humanity
inside their eyes is just not there
anymore and yeah they labeled those
people cowards and that kind of sucks
bringing it back to Whitt see he almost
certainly suffered from PTSD as well as
just numerous health problems associated
with gas exposure while he was in France
in November of 1921 just over 3 years
after his heroic stand in the Argon
Forest Charles Wy book passage from New
York to Havana aboard a ship on the
first night out in Port commits suicide
by jumping overboard his friends were
saddened but sadly not surprised
considering him one of the Lost
battalions last casualties as the years
have passed the Lost Battalion in the
first world war as a whole have been
largely forgotten overshadowed by more
recent conflicts in particular World War
II speaking again as a content creator
writer um host for numerous channels
yeah people love World War II we even
have a word for him um weaboos a
portmanto of like wart and weeaboo of
people are we L obsessed with learning
and talking about World War II I say
someone who written about World War II a
lot because it's where the money is
online unfortunately with the exception
of a TV movie released in 2001 in the
aforementioned song by the heavy metal
band Sabaton the event has mostly faded
into history which is bizarre
considering just the inherent drama of
it all it also does a great diservice to
the men who fought in that conflict men
who gave up their quiet civilian
occupations to go through hell in a
foreign land because their government
asked them to the men of a lost
Battalion deserve better than being
forgotten and we hope this year as we
commemorate Armistice Day or Veterans
Day in the United States that you'll all
think about those who fought for their
lives in the are gone both the on buried
in French cemeteries and the ones who
came home carrying the scars of War both
visible and
invisible yes so thank you for watching
this episode of biographics I certainly
found it interesting to um read through
the script and host hopefully you folks
at home also found it interesting if you
liked it leave a like you got anything
to say about it anything else you like
to cover something we missed any details
from it that you know we know we know
you we ofo's out there want to correct
us on you can absolutely do so in the
comments below and subscribe for more
content like this as always I've been
your host Cal Smallwood this has been a
video scripted by Ben Adelman you can
find links to our socials below and I
guess I'll just end with the story since
form this video is planned to go out on
November 11th like armis this day over
here in the UK Veterans Day for you
Americans it's about my granddad so my
granddad was a royal Marine he never
fought in any of the conflict he was
proud of being a royal Marine um he
didn't fight in any conflicts but you
know he was very proud that he was a
royal Marine like you know his Naval um
history and every year he would go for a
meet up with his um Old Navy buddies for
an event called the black top which to
my understanding was just this
commemorative event a lot of sailors
celebrate and because I think up until
like very recently like at least
recently considering like what it
involves um Sailors would be given a
ration of rum um I think it was like
half a pint a day at one point which
they would mix with water to create Grog
as the like you know the Royal Navy
became more and more advanced they
realized well we can't have all our
Sailors being run all the time um so
they like they kept lowering down the
ration to it like basically just became
a shot a tot of run and um even that was
deemed to be like okay we can't just
keep giving like our Sailors room it's
probably a bad idea if people in charge
like billions of dollars worth of
military technology to be drunk on rum
so they said we're going to stop giving
away rations of beer or Rum um from this
point onwards so yeah this is a
tradition that's going to end and they
celebrated that with what they called
the black top where um Sailors and
members of the Navy just took put one
last top of rum and they threw their
barrels containing the rum overboard so
once a year my Grandad would meet up
with his friends from the Navy and
they'd celebrate this they all have a
TOS of Romans share old stories about
being in it when my Grandad passed
comrades I guess like just his friends
in the Navy and took a collection and uh
had a bronze elephant commissioned um
because he was stationed aboard the HMS
Ganges so they had a big bronze elephant
Ganges India elephants and they put that
above a big flag pole so every year
during the um the arm day parades where
you know all members of the military go
a nice big parade you I always just look
out for the elephant cuz you'll see a
like you say see a old My granda's Old
Navy buddies still proudly carrying the
flag with the elephant up top which they
call Sam's elephant maybe like if you
want to put you know tell story about my
granddad so when I'm watching the
parades on November 11th I look out like
that's my granddad's elephant that's
Sam's elephant that's a true story look
look out for it Sam's
elephant